Fox News Alert dramatic new video
showing 24 hostages in Red Cross Vans
being driven to safety after spending
nearly 50 days in captivity by the
terrorists known as Hamas among them are
13 Israeli women and children but no
Americans were freed fighting in Gaza
pausing for the first time since the war
started way back on October 7th and this
is for a 4-day truce President Biden is
reacting for the first time from the
moment M kidnapped these people I along
with my team have worked around the
clock to secure the release teddy bear
is waiting to greet those children at
the hospital are a stark reminder of the
trauma these children have been through
and at such a very young age we expect
more hostages to be released tomorrow
and more the day after and more the day
after that
CH be exended by a few days or more I
think the chances are real I don't trust
toas to do anything right I only trust
toas to respond to pressure we're
hearing that more hostages could be
released tomorrow Jeff Paul is live in
southern Israel with more on this
Jeff yeah Joey and on top of the 133 who
were released as you mentioned we are
learning another 13 likely to be
released tomorrow the Israeli government
confirming they do have a list of names
and they're in the process of calling
all the families of the hostages to let
them know exactly who is on that list
and who is not it's a bit of a
Bittersweet though development when you
realize there are still more than 200
people according to the Israeli
government who are being held hostage by
Hamas but today nonetheless was a huge
and significant first step now here's we
know here's what we know about who was
released 24 people so far being released
by Hamas 13 Israelis 11 foreign
Nationals among the Israelis freed we
know four were kids ages ranging from 2
years old to 9 years old one of those
kids Ohad under actually turned 9 years
old while being held by Hamas now three
were also mothers and six are elderly
women so far the truce between Israel
and Hamas appears to be holding but IDF
spokesperson Daniel hagari says even
with the pause in fighting Israeli
forces remain focused on one of their
core objectives and that's rooting out
Hamas during the days of the pause the
IDF will continue the preparations for
the next phases of the war DF troops are
ready and prepared on all the
fronts now this was the moment when a
convoy of rescue hostages passed by a
group of Israelis they were cheering and
clapping just knowing some of those
people were finally getting home and it
is critical though this ceasefire keeps
up to continue that flow with the pause
in fighting though several different Aid
trucks made their way into Gaza
delivering things like Fuel and cooking
gas we also know that 33 Palestinian
prisoners both women and teenagers were
released from Israel so the next couple
days are going to be critical we know
again another 13 will be released
tomorrow if this truce holds it looks
like more Aid will be getting in and the
next day after that we'll see the same
thing happening we're also learning
tonight that the hospital where the kids
were taken Schneider hospital here uh in
Israel they're reporting that the kids
appear to be in good condition Joey
thanks Jeff stay safe and as we pray for
the safe return of all the hostages the
liberal media is once again making an
absolute fool out of themselves over
this very topic take a look at this
Israeli spokesman's stunned reaction
over a bizarre question about the
hostage deal I was speaking to a hostage
negotiator this morning he made the
comparison between the 50 hostages
hostages that Hamas has promised um
promised to release as opposed to the
150 50 prisoners that are Palestinians
that Israel has said that it will
release and he made the comp comparison
between the numbers and the fact that
does Israel not think that Palestinian
lives are valued as highly as Israeli
lives that is an astonishing accusation
if we could release one prisoner for
every one hostage we would obviously do
that we're operating in horrific
circumstances yeah that look really says
it all and if that wasn't crazy enough
anti-israel protesters we're going to
glue their hands to the ground today and
trying to disrupt the Macy's
Thanksgiving Parade yesterday there were
more protests happening today including
these folks who shouted at President
Biden while he was in
[Applause]
Nantucket
Katie I'm want to with this idea of them
chanting free Palestine I was on Seventh
Street yesterday and a big group came
down behind me but let's take it back to
the Tactical side of this because we
have two Wars happening once we have a
ground war and we have a propaganda or
information war and you know I've gone
back and forth a lot of conversations on
this but what do you think this release
that that Hamas was willing to come to
the table I mean their most valuable
asset are these hostages what does this
mean tactically and with the information
war that they're willing to release
hostages well first I would say to those
who are still screaming Free Palestine
you've had a ceasefire now so that was
supposed to be something that was a
negotiation piece and they're still
doing it which proves that they don't
want Israel to exist at all but clearly
the reason we're here uh with the
ceasefire and the release of hostages is
not because of just diplomatic
negotiations that are happening in Qatar
where the Iranian prime minister was
visiting either yesterday or the day
before it's because of Israel's military
action in the Gaza Strip to pressure
them to come to the table uh now we
don't know where all these hostages are
Hamas says that they are trying to
locate them within the Gaza Strip we
know that some Palestinian Gaza
residents took some of them hostage to
to keep them for payment other groups
like Islamic Jihad also had some of
these hostages so locating where they
are is very difficult but it really does
contrast in terms of the numbers 50
Israeli hostages for 150 Palestinian
terrorists these are not people who are
taken from their homes and slaughtered
or Taken ostage from a music festival
these are people who attempted to kill
Israeli soldiers who attempted to kill
Israeli citizens and they are now being
equated as the same thing they are not
finally I would say Hamas is still
continuing the psychological warfare uh
they returned a woman today who they
claimed was dead so her family believed
for many many weeks that she was not
around uh thank God she was returned but
they know what they're doing in terms of
psychological warfare and again this is
a group that is holding babies hostage
and we hear a lot about war crimes and
international law that is one of the
violations and maybe people should focus
on that a little more than what Israel
is doing Jimmy back to that very odd
interview on Sky News where somehow they
tried to say that I guess um an Israeli
life is worth more I didn't really
understand even what she was trying to
say but ultimately you got basically one
hostage for every three prisoners these
are completely innocent life versus
three people who have committed crimes
and been convicted uh plus they stopped
AAL surveillance they had to stop their
assault Hamas is going to rebuild or at
least try to regain some footing about
themselves they're they're so scattered
that Israel get a good deal do you think
they were pressure to do it well I think
there was a lot of pressure to do this
but I think what's so frustrating is
they tried to frame them as moral equals
yeah in that Israel chooses to do
business in this fashion Israel is in an
impossible situation right now they're
not trading as Katie said good people
for good people okay one side are
civilians that were taking hostage
against their will one side is a bunch
of th Thugs and murderers but they've
gotten used to getting their way when it
comes to these hostage exchanges I mean
we did a hostage exchange with Iran
where we sent over billions of dollars
and we sent over more people than we got
back and that's always been the status
quo because we value life more than they
do and that's what makes it so
frustrating is when they try to
establish a moral equivalency you
realize there is none one side is
willing to kill babies one side is
willing to paraglide into a RAV and kill
innocent civilians the other side's
going out of its way to avoid those
casualties tsy if if there is any
pressure coming to Israel you have to
believe some of it might be from the B
Administration which I will go on a limb
and say the bid Administration should be
trying to get Americans home like that
should be a priority I want to play a
quick uh clip here from President Biden
on what he thinks is the Catalyst for
all of
this I cannot prove what I'm about to
say but I believe one of the reasons why
Hamas struck when they did was they knew
that I was working very closely with the
Saudis and others in the region to bring
peace to the region by having
recognition of Israel and Israel's right
to exist there's overwhelming interest
and I think most Arab Nations know it in
coordinating with one another to change
the dynamic in their region for longer
term peace and uh that is uh one I'm
going to continue to work on now I want
to note an Israeli spokesperson
basically backed that up and did give
him some credit but if I look at the
previous administration you've got
Abraham Accords moving the embassy to
Jerusalem killing a chief lieutenant in
the in the Iranian terrorist
Army in my opinion is this an American
posture that drove uh that drove hos to
do this or is this more Regional uh look
I think I think it's both we have to
look at the bigger picture and and I
don't disagree with what he said and
it's clear that that what they wanted to
accomplish is actually happening and
that that's the terrible thing um you
know we talk about different types of
warfare that are occurring the
information Warfare the psychological
operation away okay completely uh it
those those talks have stopped uh
completely and any progress that was
being made in that direction has has
gone away but when you listen to that
Sky news reporter and the question that
she asked she's in she's emblematic of
this broader issue we're seeing with
many so-called reporters who aren't just
reporting facts but instead essentially
doing hamas's work for them hamas's goal
is to turn the world against Israel in
order to reach their their objective
goal and the goal of other islamist
groups and and countries frankly which
is wipe Israel off the face of the Earth
they're succeeding in doing that by
using these reporters who are have
become their propagandists and those who
are are naturally compassionate by
Nature are hearing this and and hearing
things that are that are not
representative of the truth and and
falling for it and turning against
Israel and and not actually seeing the
truth of of how islamists and terrorist
groups like Hamas as you know Isis and
al-qaed and others they have always used
civilians as human Shields they have
always hidden behind them for this this
exact reason because they know that the
news media many of them will throw this
propaganda out there without telling the
full story about their barbaric tactics
and and their their willingness to
sacrifice women and children innocent
civilians to achieve their objective and
so people need to understand the whole
truth on this this whole this whole War
part of this whole truth doctor is the
fact that these hostages come home and
they are going to be treated well but at
some point Israel has to go in and they
have to ask them questions they have to
get some information from they have
heard conversations and they maybe how
many people were in this room or that
room how difficult is that going to be
for those hostages well certainly one of
the biggest uh disappointments I had
today when the president spoke was he
still said he has no idea the conditions
of the American host hostages we don't
even have an accurate number of how many
Americans are still being held hostage
there and yet as Jimmy pointed out
Israel values life and that is why there
is a ceasefire right now and they have
decided to put pause on their ground
operation knowing that they are
prolonging how many how much longer
innocent civilians are still going to be
in these tunnels of Terror and so yes we
are so grateful that some were returned
today but they are still many down there
we don't know how they're doing and the
emotional and physical aspects and the
consequences of being down in these
tunnels they're going to be very
longlasting and yes they are going to
have to speak to authorities and they're
going to have to recount these traumas
and as you know Joey once you have
experience trauma that is something that
will stick with you for your entire life
and they're going to have to recount it
over and over again yeah I only hope
that what they've learned in servicing
veterans here the last 20 years I hope
some of that is applied I I hope that if
nothing else our our sacrifice and more
can be helpful in that way absolutely
but as you know it is a tough road and
there are still Americans and many
innocent civilians being kept in these
tunnels of Terror well we know some of
the families are still broken up so some
of people that did get released today
have families members that are hostage
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else